[Music]
violinist charles yang
and pianist peter dugan have played both
carnegie hall and the kennedy center
[Music]
but these days if you're lucky you'll
find them playing an empty storefront
on a random street corner on manhattan's
upper west side
the musicians aren't exactly roughing it
steinway donated the grand piano
and they're getting a decent salary
thanks to a local philanthropist who
came up with the idea
this is not our typical performance
experience by a long shot but
it's one of the first shows that we've
been able to do
for an actual live audience in
so long we're very grateful that we can
do it here for people that might not
go to a concert hall or an arena and
just hear different kinds of music that
they might not
have liked before
still these are precarious times for
performers
according to the local chapter of the
american federation of musicians
95 percent of their 7 000 local members
are out of work we've never experienced
anything like this
certainly artists careers have pretty
much disappeared
except for online performances and
things like that but it's just not the
same feeling
and of course there's not as much work
to go around concert halls and
performance spaces like the iconic
lincoln center
were among the first places to close in
the pandemic
and they're likely to be the last ones
to reopen not only depriving musicians
of their livelihoods
but also new york of its lifeblood
60 shows with 100 performers have been
scheduled
organizers can't say where or when for
fear of drawing too large a crowd
[Music]
but word is starting to get around this
neighborhood known for the arts
it just gives me this energy and it
makes new york feel a little bit more
the way i think new york should feel to
be that close and be able to see them
the performers interact with each other
was really fascinating i usually can't
afford seats that close
a bit like a musical scavenger hunt in a
time
and a neighborhood where such a
performance is the ultimate prize
kristin salumi al jazeera new york